hey what's up on today's show we're
gonna be talking about how to deal with
a nine-year-old who's not following
directions who's lying and is otherwise
causing chaos in the house
we're gonna be talking about how to
become friends
with your partner's ex we're gonna be
talking about
how to let mom go and make friends and
make peace
with your dad's new wife after your
mom's passed away
stay tuned
hey what's up i'm john this is the
doctor john deloney show
we're taking calls about your life your
adventures
your marriages your relationships
[Music]
your homeschooling adventures however
good that's going or not good that's
going
we might even be talking about people
who don't know how to say no
wherever you are if you're watching this
if you are driving if you're mowing the
lawn i just want you to say it out loud
no i can't come pick up your whatever or
do your
whatever it is just say the word no
right after i get off this podcast i'm
gonna sprint across town
because i can't say no and i said sure
i'll come do the thing i'll do the
uh it's just a pathology in my soul and
so i'm taking my grievances out on
myself
to everyone listening just practice
saying no we're gonna be talking about
everything right
so whatever's going on in your heart and
your mind or your universe i'm here to
walk with you so give me a call
six nine 1-844-693 thirty two ninety one
that's one
eight four four six nine three thirty
two
ninety one feel free to email me at ask
john
ramsey solutions dot com that's ask john
ramsey solutions dot
com all right let's go straight to the
phones
to lisa in oklahoma city lisa good
morning how are we doing
i'm okay how are you i'm doing okay
doing okay so how can i help this
morning um my husband and i
are having some difficulty disciplining
our nine-year-old son
okay tell me about it he's very defiant
and he's always been that way
and sometimes i feel like we're kind of
in this chicken and egg
sort of deal because i don't know if
us being more strict on him because of
the defiance and sneakiness now and the
lying
that it's contributing to the behavior
so we don't know if we need to back off
a little bit
if he needs maybe some counseling we're
kind of worried with the teen years
coming up what's going to be happening
and
but we definitely don't feel like what
we're doing or what we've tried has ever
worked
do you have other kids in your house we
do
and we have four kids one is now off to
college
and and then we have a 16 year old and
then we also have a seven-year-old
16 year old and a seven-year-old and
then a nine-year-old are the rest of
your kids perfect little angels and
wonderful and you just have one outlier
or do they have their own series of
challenges oh yes they all do they're
all different and our youngest is a girl
so that's
even different challenges and
and they've all kind of you know had
their moment
and learned from them and we feel like
we're kind of
on this path where he's not learning
from the consequences
whether they're even natural
consequences or consequences we've given
them
and we've tried reward systems before
and we're not seeing
a lot of progress we get a lot of calls
from school ever since he's been in
kindergarten
or preschool even and i actually kept
him home
for his first grade year to try to
homeschool him to see if we could
progress through because a lot of times
the schools want to hold them back
for the behavior and i just felt like he
wasn't
that wasn't necessary for his behavior
because he is a
he's a good kid and if you let him do
whatever he wants
he's great
most of us are awesome when we can do
whatever we want i know
so here's a couple of hard questions and
i want to preface this with
moms sometimes hear these and dads hear
these is accusational and that's not
that's not the case here i just want to
kind of dig in a little bit okay
um where does he learn this behavior
where is he learning sneakiness
where does he learn um
deceit he's lying where does he learn
those behaviors
and that's a good question
he does a lot of back talking too and i
feel like that's definitely something
he's learned from
everyone in the family all of us kind of
argue
together in front of each other so i
know that's part of that
but um the lying and sneakiness i'm not
sure
and my older two boys have been pretty
honest with us as far as we can
tell as parents well so put your put
your other boys aside
okay are you and your husband always
straightforward with one another
or do you roll your eyes at each other
or does he come in and sneak
ice cream every once in a while or do
you say well now that your dad's not
here
does your son hear that kind of back and
forth
confusing character talk i do say maybe
a couple of times we've said that and
i've caught myself
and i don't know if my husband does when
i'm not around
but um i have caught myself doing that
like my daughter will say hey dad's not
around let's do this and i'll say okay
look don't tell your dad or things like
that and then i
i realize that it's bad to be doing that
so one of the one of the first things i
always want to do when a parent is
experiencing a series of behaviors from
their kids
i always want to back out 30 000 feet
and i want to go to the mirror first
and i need to be honest with myself
about
where is my kid picking these things up
where is my kid
learning that lying works in this house
that talking back to so in my house like
my son
disrespecting my wife or my daughter
does that work in my house
where does my son see people say one
thing
and do another thing we don't lie in
this house
hey don't tell your dad but we're gonna
get some ice cream we're gonna stop at
sonic on the way home you cannot blow
like burn me on this one right where
does he pick up
those incongruencies so that's number
one um
i really think a lot of parents don't
don't realize what their kids are
absorbing from them
and just what's the air they're
breathing that's number one number two
you've got other kids in the house and
it may be picking up
how do you interact with them as one
transition to college
what was your life like did you
did that hit you hard did you have some
moments where you had some low seasons
did you and your husband or your husband
and your
in your oldest did they fight did they
get a little more snippy
and here's here's what i'm asking that
feel relational gaps or tension in the
home
with this idea that it's my fault and i
have to bridge that gap
the kid feels like they've got to bridge
that gap and so often what you will find
is a kid who
realizes when i talk back i get yelled
at
i get in trouble but when i get in
trouble
i get mom's total attention she looks me
in the eye
she grabs my shoulder she holds my face
when i lie to dad he will come in my
room and shut the door
and it's just me and him and kids learn
that when there's tension in the house
and they can relieve it they can get the
the focus
back on them by bridging that gap they
will
learn to perform right you'll they'll
learn to
get straight a's and be the goody
two-shoe kid
or they will learn to steal and to get
their
their connection in other ways it's the
same behavior i mean
it's different behaviors but it's the
same root issue right
and so one of the things i always
recommend to parents
is spend a season spend 30 days and have
this
hard hard conversation with your husband
you all got to be on the same page here
and i'm not saying it's hard because
he's a husband i'm saying it's hard
because y'all too have to decide
that we are going to look at our
nine-year-old's behavior as his yelling
as his um talk back is his dishonesty
whatever that is going on there we're
gonna look at that
as a set of skills he's not picked up
he's not learned
less moral failures we're not going to
say he's a bad guy
we're not going to say he's failing us
we're going to say
we haven't taught him and we're going to
invest in that and here's where you're
going to start number one you're going
to start
catching him doing good and so i've got
a young son
who is a ball of energy he gets
his dad's complete distract ability
he got it directly from me as though i
mainlined it into him
both environmentally and genetically and
what i've started to do is to say to
call him hank get in here
and i use the same tone of voice and he
comes in he says yes sir
and i say close that door and it closes
it and i'll walk up to him and i'll put
my hand on his face
and i'll look him in the eye and say i
heard how you just treated your sister
and i'm so grateful for you
i am so grateful that you are the kind
of brother who respects his sister
who treats her with dignity who lets her
just have that last piece of candy
because it's not worth the fight and
because she's worth the extra piece of
candy
and so i've made it a point to catch him
doing good sometimes i'll get him out of
bed when he's going to bed
and i'll call him in there where he's
put his dishes away and i'll say hey
i want to let you know that this was a
big help to your mom
this is a big help to me and this shows
a lot of character that when people eat
they clean up their own dishes in this
house and i just want to say thank you
and
it is changing him from the inside out
because he no longer has to
be defiant he no longer has to lie or to
be loud he
he didn't struggle with dishonesty but
he struggled with some other behaviors
and he didn't have to do that anymore
because he knows i'm watching i've got
his attention
and here's the last thing i'm going to
tell you um
you have to get with your husband you
all got to get off site and i want you
to
take a pen and a piece of paper and i
want you to write down a set of family
values
and those family values are going to be
the values that you you live by
that he lives by and that you do not
tolerate any deviants from your kids
and what does that mean we're going to
be on the same page
about being honest we're not gonna have
hey don't tell your mom or don't tell
your dad
if a kid lies in our home we will be
very swift to respond with punishments
a hundred percent of the time and i'm
talking no holds barred punishments
i will take the court of the tv for a
month i will
take the controllers out of the video
game and you can
get them back next year whatever right
so i'm being
i'm joking about the severity there but
you have to have consequences to
values based behavior you will not be
disrespectful to my wife in my house
i tell my son i tell my daughter you
will not disrespect your older brother
you will
be a person who is kind i tell my son
you will be kind to the person
who is helping us at the restaurant
period
those are values-based behaviors in my
home you will tell the truth
period in my home so we don't we don't
fudge on those we don't move those
around
i don't blink at those and that's a big
deal so
back up look at your whole system look
at you and your husband
interact with one another with your
other kids where is your son learning
these behaviors
catch him being good don't make a
nine-year-old have to fill the
relational gap you go to him
even i know you got four kids you got
three of them at home i know it's
exhausting it's tiring
that's the job as a parent you go to him
and then i want you all to draw some
hard
hard lines on values in your family and
then announce them to your kids
and then don't don't blink don't budge
so thanks for the call
thanks for the call lisa all right let's
go to the next caller let's go to
danielle in san antonio texas
danielle good morning how are we doing
i'm good how are you dr j
dude i'm doing good so what's up how can
i help
hey so um i have um a kind of a
complicated question
but my main goal is i really really want
to
cultivate a relationship with my
husband's ex-wife
there's you know everything associated
with
custody there's lots of drama and so i
just
really really want to try and get to a
point where we can have a relationship
and overlook um you know the last few
years build drama
so where where does your relationship
stand now
um right now it's very very formal very
cordial
and i know that's that's something to
strive for but i really just want
something um
authentic something that i'm not scared
of
uh being vulnerable in some kind of way
with her but um
right now i just feel like everything
you know like we're right in the middle
of a custody battle so everything's
being looked at by the courts everything
has been
you know text messages are being
screenshotted and so i just
want to reach some kind of level where
we are
authentic in our relationship i'm not
sure if that makes sense yeah absolutely
so number one i want to applaud you i
think what you're doing is noble
and i think what you're doing is holy
and i think what you're doing is just
acting like a grown up
so high five to you all the way to texas
um i i i wish more adults in the world
would act like you're acting
which is i've married a guy who's
got a child with another woman i've
married a woman who's got a child
another guy
that means they're going to be in my
life and the the more peace
i can have relationally the more i can
be on the same page
with their ex the better my life's going
to be the better my new husband's life's
going to be and the better the life of
this kid's going to be so high five
to you danielle um here's what i would
recommend right now you mentioned you're
in the middle of a custody battle
yes sir um we are we're right at the end
of it you know
um it was a very long process but we
have our final hearing
in october and we should get some kind
of permanent
um custody schedule that there won't be
any fighting of
you know well she said we could have
this or he said i could do this kind of
stuff
just something more permanent you know
yeah i think that's really wise to let
the courts weigh in especially when
things are still tense and on fire
so what you're asking to do right now
think of it this way
is your home is on fire and your husband
scooped up one kid and you grabbed the
dog and some pictures
and on your way out the door you're
talking to your husband about his
favorite recipes
like you know what we should start
eating at home more and probably have a
little bit
safer meat and we should eat a little
more vegetables
and what he's probably going to tell you
is the house is on fire we need to get
out this isn't the moment to have that
conversation
and so think of a custody battle think
of
somebody else a court system deciding
when you can see
the most important relationship in your
life your son or daughter
they're telling you not on these days on
these days and
you're telling somebody else these day
that is a that is a amygdala fire
that is somebody's soul is on fire and
it's not a great time to
develop a deep relationship what you can
do right now
is to be really respectful really kind
all you can control is you in this
situation right
if text messages are being taken out of
context if text messages and emails
electronic communication is being
heard aggressively or frustrating or
angry
then don't send them right don't send
them and wait for the smoke to clear on
this
wait for there to be a decision and
that's when
a phone call or a text message that says
we're both going to be involved in this
child's life we're both going to be
involved in this man's life
and i'd love to have a cordial
relationship with you
for the sake of the child for the sake
of both of our
relationships and just life harmony and
peace
and my hope is that this your husband's
ex will be wise and will accept that and
will
say oh thank god i want to have that
relationship too
she might not she may say dude i don't
want anything to do with you you're the
one who broke up my family and ruined
everything and put everything on you
right
um but i think it's worth that shot now
just doesn't sound like a good time
as you back out is she gonna be a good
mom
to your um
i guess you're not gonna be an adoptive
i guess you haven't you're not adopting
this child huh so is she gonna be a good
mom to this to this
this kid no absolutely i mean
um my husband and i both feel like she
um the child's never in danger there's
there's uh they have a good relationship
um it's it was just the issue
that the mom was trying to keep my
husband away from
his daughter and so um
i don't know i feel like she's a really
good mom i don't
i don't fear at all for the kids safety
it's just the relationship between my
husband and her
and then her and i that i really really
want to
work on and strive for more
because um you know like i love this
little girl so much and
she deserves to have all three of her
parents
you know um not fighting over petty
stuff and i just i just don't know how
to reach
that point and it's best because we're
geographically dislocated so it's not
like i can just you know
go up to where they live and say hey
let's go have breakfast and talk about
okay it's always through text messages
it's always through phone calls and
um i did try at some point about
six months ago when all this started
popping off um
to to reach out to her um and she
kind of ignored my text so i don't know
i feel like because i wear my heart
even so i feel like i'm trying too hard
and
i just i'm not getting anything back so
yeah
you might be trying too hard and my
guess is with a custody battle with how
long have you been married to this guy
uh we've been married for two years yeah
so you're still in a new marriage
and you jumped into a blended family now
right so there's a new marriage he's got
a relationship with another woman still
he's got a kid in the house
my guess is you're trying to control
what you can control which is some of
this tension
and your way of controlling tension is
so noble and so good but it's through
connection and relationship which is the
right thing
the challenge with connection and with
the relationship is those
those things come they go both ways
right the plug has to fit
into like the the cords got to fit into
the plug and the wall right
if it doesn't fit no matter how good
that plug is and how good that extension
cord
is if it doesn't go in the plug there's
not going to be any electricity there so
i need a connection so
what you're trying to do is noble and
good
my guess is you're going to have to
understand that you chose to marry
somebody who's in the middle of a
custody battle
you chose to marry somebody who's got a
kid by somebody else
all fine but with that comes tension
with that comes learning how to be in
relationship
and different kinds of relationships and
with those things come discomfort come
come frustration come man i wish we
could just sit and have a conversation
well some people just want to have a
conversation because they're immature
they're upset they're heartbroken
500 other reasons so yeah i wouldn't try
too hard
i would slow down exhale focus your
energy on your thoughts
and on your actions which what you can
control right now is
making sure your husband's loved making
sure that baby's loved
making sure that what work you do is
excellent
and making sure that when you respond or
communicate with his ex because you have
to you are so respectful and you are so
kind and you follow the court's orders
but you also follow human orders you
just treat her with dignity like i know
you're doing
and then once the smoke clears on this
deal once the ashes aren't so hot
that's when you reach out and say i'd
love to have a relationship with you be
prepared for her to say lady i don't
like you i don't want you in my life
don't ever contact me again be prepared
for that because some people are
immature and some people
can't deal but also be be prepared for
her to say
i'm in i am in we're never going to be
besties
i don't even want to hug and like you
know go down on the river walk there in
san antonio i don't want to do that with
you
but we are going to be cordial we can be
we can become somewhat friends
and man what a gift good for you
danielle good for you
so let's go back to the phones let's
take one more let's go to holly
in celina kansas holly what is up how
are we doing
hi dr d great to talk to you and also
with you
i am having trouble accepting my dad's
behavior
since my mom passed away um he
he moved on very quickly a couple months
after she died
started dating someone new and then it
was full speed ahead you know proposed
living together
spending a lot of money on her that he
would never have spent
on my mom he's always been very frugal
and smart with money
and you know after 45 years with my mom
it's hard for me to see him not only
with someone new but also
spending so out of character and just it
seems to me like giving her all the
things that he wouldn't give to my mom
you know she would have loved to spend
all that money but he always had her on
a budget
and you know it's hard for me in so many
ways to to not only see him showering
another woman with affection but you
know also with
with things holly can i
can i tell you i know it doesn't feel
like it
but you are way way ahead of the
grieving game right now
and here's why because you are
recognizing that this
that you're not okay with this yeah
it usually takes a lot of hard
conversations with folks
to get them to realize you're not trying
to protect dad you're not trying to
protect this new person you're just sad
you don't think it's fair
you love your old mom and you wanted
things to be a certain way and they're
not
and that you're the one wrestling with
this i want to tell you holly that's a
hard place to get to so high five to you
we're not gonna high five we're gonna
hug like hug from yeah from kansas to
nashville on this deal
um so thank you tell me about your mom
tell me about her um
well she was a nurse for 40 years worked
really hard
and uh six months after she retired
uh found out she had cancer and then
spent the last two years of her life
battling that so you know i have some
guilt as far as like
she never got to enjoy her retirement
and all that money she worked really
hard for
and you know my dad
was always they always were really smart
on you know saving and planning for
their retirement
together so i guess i wish she got to
enjoy that and it's hard for me to see
someone new enjoying the fruits of her
labor
yeah now i i wish there was a magic
thing to say
other than that sucks i can imagine that
being hard
did your mom love your dad oh yeah
um and i just hold on did she love him
like in a
very dutiful kansas mom kind of way or
did she love him like it
recklessly she just thought he was one
of those hung the moon kind of guys
she was a soldier side by side with him
you know she put up with a lot
and and you know she stuck by him so
you know it's you know i wish that she
would have gone to enjoy
all these years where you know really
she just worked her whole life
yeah and but she got to look i want to
back up a little
a second she got to work she did she had
to go to work every day she saved money
she
followed these plans that your dad laid
out and they did together i get that
but she also got to help people for 40
years
yeah she got to fill in a gap of when
people were hurting
when they were disconnected when they
were broken when they were just
weeping and hurting and i'll add hurting
again
sitting with folks who are hurting is
one of the greatest gifts one of the
hardest jobs in the world but it's a
gift
and so your mom lived a full beautiful
life right
right yeah she did that's incredible
i want you to honor that for her right
right
so here's the the hardest question i'm
going to ask you
would your mom
like would you best honor your mom
by having a hard conversation with your
dad and saying i don't like the way
you're spending money i don't like this
new lady in our house
or would you best honor your mom which
she would wink at you
if you said dad you're a [ __ ]
but go get him buddy what's the best way
you could honor your mom
well i feel like being angry
i'm the only one that's hurt by it
because
he's moved on and he's happy and this
new woman is certainly happy because
she's getting all these things
so i just thought well she could be
happy because she loves the guy but
whatever
well yeah um but i guess i don't i want
to honor
my mom by not forgetting her and i feel
like he just moved on so quickly
that he didn't really honor and grieve
her i felt like he just was trying to
fill the void as quickly as possible and
that's
i guess what's making me hold on to this
is
like i feel like when i accept him with
this new person
i'm letting her go yeah
and here's the thing holly you're gonna
have to let her go
gonna have to let the wonderful mother
the wonderful
co-pilot with your dad this
extraordinary nurse who served the least
of these for 40 years you're gonna have
to let her go
and that doesn't mean you forget her
that doesn't mean you don't honor her
it does mean you don't punish your dad
and what what happened is he's trying to
grind out a life
is he numbing did he jump back in a
relationship trying to pretend this
never happened probably
yeah probably yes yeah and you can
you can beat him up for it and i know a
lot of 60 year old men
millions of them who don't know how to
grieve
they don't know what that even looks
like they don't know what purpose
i mean they don't they don't have the
skill set for that they don't the tool
set for that
and some go on an arduous journey to
find it
and others just say you know what i'm
gonna skid out life with no more tread
left on my tires
and i earned this money i had this
picture i was gonna spend it with this
woman
it didn't work out we're gonna rock and
roll till the wheels fall off with
somebody else
is that the most healthy way probably
not in fact no it's not
um is that my place as
as a as a kid to sit down and try to
piece that take that from my father i
don't think so
um i don't think so it's kind of like
telling a dad who's
overweight you know having yet another
conversation about well should you be
eating that
at some point you know they're 60 years
old they're 70 years old they're going
to do what they're going to do what
they're going to do
and i get to choose well i'm going to
love them and just be with them
whether i'm going to fully embrace their
new chaotic life
even if that means you know that they're
going to be he's going to be divorced in
four years
and he's going to need a place to live
like you know what i mean it's just kind
of like
here here maybe this is a bad analogy
this is what i'm going to give you
you ever you have little kids uh yeah
two months old okay this may be a
terrible analogy but i'm going to use it
anyway
it's my show right um so let's pretend
your kid's a five-year-old
and you hand them is it a girl or a boy
a boy you hand that little boy a thing
of cotton candy
and he starts eating it and he gets a
little bit on his nose and on his cheek
and you stop and you wipe it and then
you turn around to talk to somebody and
you
you turn back around and he's got cotton
candy from the top of his head to the
bottom of his chin
it's in his nose it's everywhere and
there just comes that moment when you
say
you know what dude just get it just
eat the cotton candy that doesn't mean
you're a bad mom
that doesn't mean that you don't love
your kid that doesn't mean you don't
care about
his clothes or how he look that means in
this moment i'm
i'm just gonna i'm gonna love you and go
get him buddy right
and i'm not saying your dad's new wife
is cotton candy right but there comes a
moment when
you said it best you're only hurting
yourself you're only poisoning
what years you have left with your dad
and you might be poisoning a new
friendship with this woman and so
have you ever taken her out for coffee
and just said i want to get to know you
no no okay i want to strongly
with all of my heart holly recommend you
do that because you might find that
she's not as bad as you thought you she
you might find she's terrible she may be
the worst
right but my guess is your dad's a
person a character
your dad knows how to pick them because
he picked one real well
and he is picking somebody to ride jet
skis with
for as long as he's got left and yeah
it is what it is i get morning and just
know that by celebrating your dad
celebrating your mom's life
you're not diminishing her you're not
forgetting her
but you are letting her go you are
letting me go
yeah well i will do my best thank you
very much
remember this growing through grief is
about making meaning
and you can only grow through grief with
relationships
and so as again calling her this
this new woman and saying hey you're in
my life right wrong or indifferent
let's get together sitting down with
your dad and saying tell me what you
love about this new lady trying to hear
it and figure it out
it's going to be weird it's going to be
awkward it's going to be uncomfortable
but it's the best you can do there's the
old
quote in the alcoholics anonymous group
that you know holding on to resentment
holding on to this type of of hatred
is like poisoning yourself and hoping
somebody else dies right
and holly and holly you know that right
we all know that
that being angry and frustrated other
people
i just it just weighs me down right and
we also know this
this heart-wrenching
if i accept this new person that means i
gotta let my mom go
i gotta let her go she lived an
incredible life
like she said she was a soldier
i gotta let her go i'm still gonna
remember her i'm still gonna honor her
i'm still gonna love her memory but i
gotta let her go
and then we're all gonna move on with
joy in our hearts we're gonna make
meaning the best we can we're never
gonna forget but we're gonna make
meaning moving forward
holly i love your question and more
importantly i love your heart
good for you good for you heal your
heart and go make some more
relationships
all right so as we wrap up today's show
i asked a co-worker what's the greatest
song ever written
and really quickly she rattled this song
off and i thought
oh goodness these youngins these young
millennials
and then i listened to the song and
realized everything i knew about the
world was a lie
this was the greatest song ever written
it was written just a few years ago
by some group who lives in the town
where i live and i didn't even know it
that's like i don't even know what to
say it's like it's like sleeping on a
on a bed of dirt with diamonds
underneath you i don't even know it's it
my heart was was it just exploded with
joy here we go here's the song
it's by the band johnny swim off their
record entitled diamonds
this is a deep cut it's called we can
take the world
they write we don't need calligraphy to
write a fancy story
kings and queens return to thieves to
find what we've been holding
you and me we can take the world
because they can write stories they can
write songs but they don't make fairy
tales sweeter than ours
they can climb mountains high into the
sky
but they can't take the world oh like we
can take the world
johnny's swim in nashville tennessee
this
is the john daloni show